[Musique]
bienvenue à sans fil aujourd'hui on a
une énorme annonce on a finalement lancé
notre pétrone ça faisait beaucoup de
temps que les gens le demandent un site
arrive et que tu en sais quoi c'est une
plate forme à ce que vous pouvez
encourager vos créateurs de contenus
préférés
qu'est-ce qu'on a d'abord piquionne les
au début on voulait pas vraiment l'enfer
parce qu'on s'est dit on voulait pas
vous achats les paras votre argent mais
l'oeil est tellement de monde qu'ils ont
dit par tvo avait tué un homme et vous
encourager que on va la prendre votre
argent c'est carré qui dans le fond ce
que ça donne qui conduit exclusif
là-dessus fac ci vous abonnez vous à
avoir des podcasts exclusif des kinés
avec moby ph
la même foi poser des questions aux
invités qui viennent peu à faire ce pas
le fondement
c'est vraiment la meilleure façon nous
encourager pour qu'on puisse trouver du
temps entre horaires pour encore
continuer à créer du contenu comme ça
donc allez voir je vous invite vraiment
et à laisser le lien notre parc futures
vont être dans la description de cette
vidéo si s'il vous plaît prenez le temps
allez voir qu'est ce qu'il ya vraiment
une option intéressante exclusive au
pétrole
sinon cette semaine à sans filtre
stéphanie harvey mets servis et joueuses
de counter strike gamers professionnels
alors on a parlé de la réalité d'être
une femme dans ce milieu le népal un
petit peu de dépendance pas sa
dépendance mehdi phénomène la dépendance
aux jeux vidéo
on ne parlait plus de policiers que
c'était la première fois qu'on entend
parler ouvertement comme ça je pense que
c'est une belle conversation que vous
pouvez écouter sinon oubliez pas de vous
abonner à cette chaîne si pour être
notifiée à chaque mardi quand ils vont
au nouveau parc à ce qui va sortir les
c'est aussi dans les commentaires ce que
vous pensez notre conversation parce que
nous on aime se voulait on aime soit
aussi vous répondre donc sur ce bon
podcast d'autres sites monaco
[Musique]
c'est parti fanny merci d'être ici un
plaisir est ce que tu veux qu'on appelle
mes services
est ce que j'imagine que le monde qui te
reconnaissent dans la rue ils te
reconnaissent comme mais c'est revenu et
je t'aiderai trop de 4 à 6 savent que
mon système là c'est vraiment parce que
c'est plus qu'une fois
lee suivent ma carrière et tout mais
c'est aussi sérieux que tu fais le plus
regardé à québec à québec le québec
parce que c'est sûr ça fait longtemps
que moi je fais ça à québec même camping
s'était pas bien que dis je faisais déjà
des petits trucs les un peu partout ses
apparitions publiques et déjà vu tension
du québec on allait le temps en temps le
pentagone a dit à l'ats denis pittet
lopy telle tous joué j'ai fait de trop
collab avec eu son bébé
il ya des gens avec qui j'aime bien
travailler fait est que je montrerai
fort peu importe le sens commun oui
ça fait longtemps nous autres on aider
on est des gamers amateurs depuis
longtemps des amateurs de gaming nous on
a l'eau james t je travaillais là aussi
cinq fois celui de l'enfant j'ai
commencé à bout pas en fait c'est là que
j'ai commencé quand des chèques la
première page à la seigneurie des cours
pour les jouer à six minutes du compte
un cinq pièces
les partisans de dîners ou
[Musique]
[Rires]
après une couple de semaines on le fait
installer chez nous puis le mac est en
forme et témoin du cinéma et on allait
trio james t un pilote juste à côté
aussi
oui juste à côté les activités offertes
sans le fait qu'on n'arrête chili leurs
plans des caisses confiance aux oraux on
pourrait d'abord tlf et maxime ont joué
à cause des quads autos ou des portes
pilaire m'amener quand j'ai eu 18 ans a
prévenu si tendres parce qu'il fallait
que chaz de 24 heures des footix à
l'alcool ouais j'ai dit star devenue
employée drame si ça a été ma première
moto bref je vais les jardins maladie
qui commença à jouer là-dessus été long
avant que tu saches que tu voulais faso
ou que donc il le fait sérieusement et
sérieusement tirer combien j'ai commencé
à le faire assez sérieusement je dirais
moi j'ai concert 2003 2004 2005
ça a été quand ils assez vite mais c'est
pas la même façon que c'est maintenant
ouais c'est sûr qu'en magie sérieusement
la city
un moment donné en 2005 il fallait j'ai
moi même parabole mauger de cerner
architecture j'arrivais pu architecture
jobs tous les soirs et les fins de
semaine plus qu'ils n'ont pas que je dis
m par an moi je veux continuer gaming
que je me dis ok c'était un des plus
beau cadeau qui m'en fait pas ça a
changé ma vie
bien qu'ils aient fait que j'ai arrêté
de travailler jusqu'à je revienne dans
les jeux vidéo
il ya des années mais en fait ça a été
ça mon sérieux ça a été je continue mes
études mais je prends le gaming au
sérieux ou six qu'il est pareil ont
réussi à comprendre parce que et je
pense deuxième temps je gagne ma
première coupe du monde
et puis l'a apprécié ça donne raison de
6 pi ca doit tellement enlevé un poids
énorme sur des surprises et pas all thy
de faire comme bon mais le kg une comète
deux ânes à vie pour le temps pitiful
tellement gaming en centaines d'autres
on faisait de notation compétition bien
après quatre heures d'entraînement par
jour
ton corps ça sert à rien tu continues tu
es mais en gaming ses postures un gaming
est encore capable d'avoir du travail
productif après quatre heures au petit
cd r cd 12 heures le td fois par jour et
ses coups que tu perds le sait pas ce
que cela des gens en fait quand
j'explique ça les gens qui comprennent
pas trop le ministre je pense et saâd
logis 30 2 c'est vraiment ce qui fait
que maintenant aujourd'hui je trouve ça
plus difficile d'être pro gamer parce
que moi après 4-5 ans césar d'un v6 en
jeu bien dans ma journée j'ai le goût de
faire d'autres choses ici avec vous
faire un autre cas ce mois normalement
je devrais pas être là je suis rendu à
l'étape où je veux m'acheter un chien
puis je vais m'en occuper c'est ça veut
dire qu'il faut que je relève de trois
heures de ma journée
parce qu'il faut que je m'en occupe et
tu sais qu'on le met ça restreint les
voyages peuvent acheter capable de faire
12 heures dans une journée
et puis ne pas avoir de problèmes
physiques le choix je veux plus costaud
que je cache plus goût à 25 à
concentration diminue
mais ça me dérange pas de rester encore
cinq ça c'est correct mais en haut de ce
je veux faire des projets je vais partir
des choses je veux faire de hockey je
pense qu'en quinzaine de photos j'ai
beaucoup donné mais ça ne tenait pas
très performant sur un mois mais dont je
suis la scène quand même du pro gaming
puis c'est rare que tu vois quelqu'un
qui reste au sommet longtemps laitiers
gens les périodes de pays clés sont
vraiment quand même cour si mettons en
natation et en mako ferme s'ils restent
au sommet pendant vingt ans il était le
meilleur nous aurons mais un gaming j'ai
l'impression en action plus talentueux
que d'autres mais j'ai l'impression que
les périodes de pays qui sont vraiment
court parce que pour être à 100% topo
bjoergen c'est un régime d'entraînement
qu'ils jugent insoutenables même moi je
trouve ça un souteneur puis ça ça parait
vraiment beaucoup en asie en fait il y
aurait il à l'apport les gros joueurs
comme ali origin fait que toutes leurs
cartes sont très très courtes sont
capables de se pousser à la limite
fatidique tremplin alors que je pense
qu'en amérique on comprend que c'est un
peu plus important d'en avoir une
balance de ville
et puis on aime bien les superstars fois
qu'on veut que les carrières dure plus
longtemps fait qu'il essaie de ne pas
trop faire de changements et mettez des
fois on se fait rattraper par les jeunes
pied c'est par elle que c est une relève
et ce qui est des nouveaux joueurs
toujours qu'il est capable à ce camp
tchèque arnost je raconte vous fait
moins c'est très difficile mais au
niveau masculin y en a vraiment beaucoup
le nouvel julie ouais ok ça paye
bouchard bonsoir way justement je m'en
veux c'était beaucoup râlent je jouais à
quel point tinghir adopte une
compétition en erreur en asie j'ai
récemment fait que le dernier week end
là les passes on a fini 3e france que
j'en vois pas que julie puis cette année
on ne remplace une chose pour julie que
parce qu'ils étaient plus performantes
quitte à prendre si le oui l'autre jeune
j'adorais vraiment beaucoup mais elle
est fille mon copain qui donne une
chance à julie et puis c'est sûr que
tout le monde c'est des bonnes personnes
tout et c'est dommage pour nous plutôt à
ce que tu as comme un statut de statut
mais ton sans dire les jambes statut
assez élevée dans le ciel féminin est ce
qu'elle est ce que ma tante était la
capitaine de l'équipe s'est un peu toile
les décisions ou ça peu plus compliqué
que ça je dirais que c'est pas comme le
sport par rapport à ça c'est gros comme
et
même si ce n'est pas le meilleur joueur
nick et était dans un esprit des
motivateurs soutien
j'irai qu'il faut d'un capitaine qui
équipera de jouer les faux que captait
reçoit alors le capitaine dans le jeu
vidéo c'est eux qui font les comme un
peu ça se compare pas foule au sport
mais c'est vraiment les joueurs qui ont
eu trois pages au stratège qui est fait
ouah je peux faire ça mais je suis comme
peut toutefois un peu le festival sera
mince affaire
les enfants que les autres j'adore ça
n'est pas rejoindre à chaque année ça
changera les équipes l année passée
c'est moi qui t'ai pour la chine que moi
j'adore ce mais je pense que je peux se
motiver c'est quelqu'un qui motive dis
je c'est positif dont j'ai aussi le gmi
mai mais présente match assez positive
dans le jeu focus beaucoup plus sur la
la synergie l'éclat comme question
comment qu'on parque pied les mots même
temps tout ce qui disparaît
partageraient dans le sport je suis
aussi de l'appliquer dans le gaming
kipré nouveau le plus performant et moi
je crois vraiment la synergie qui tient
un comment les gens se rassemblent et
s'ils sont confortables 6ème les gens
avec qui joue je suis convaincu qu'il
vaut mieux performer fait que je suis un
peu je travaille comme équipe et puis
est ce que tu penses que dans les jeux
l'équipe
il ya moins un petit peu les stéréotypes
du gamin introverti qui qui pas vraiment
habile avec les disques utilisés moment
social teams étrangers regardaient
j'aime le du monde de starcraft 2 de
finir puis le gars qui gagne est il
clairement il n'y a pas l'air d'un gars
qui est capable d'aller contre lui tu as
tu auras fréquemment un jeu de temps un
contre un il ya personne d'autre que lui
dans ses écouteurs
c'est très possible j'avais jamais pensé
à ça avant mais dites moi quand je
regarde
quand le chat que chaque team
professionnel la plupart c'était des
bodybuilders déjà qu'ils sont en train
de craquer s'il est vrai que pas celle
de jouer il ya comme une espèce de vague
heureusement d'un candidat parce que les
goûts vieilli voyage à toutes les
semaines et de s'entraîner enfin dans
les hôtels un écran très différentes
équipes s'il passe tellement de temps
ensemble
les adversaires que lorie déjà tout ce
temps perdu pour une bonne nouvelle et
c'est vrai qu'on dirait que certains
plats que vous utilisez que ça
s'améliore ton focus sont inquiets pour
les performances qui on n'a pas les
meilleurs mais c'est sûr parce que tu
dois aussi sa dose se permettent de
penser à autre chose
je me rappelle quand on n'a jamais fait
dès 12h les gaming gaming on a peut-être
fait une fois au 28 rue du blanc seau
d'eau c'est quand tu sors de là on
dirait moi j'allais me coucher pigeon
genre je rêvais encore un ace qui venait
de faire le tri puis j'avais comme le
rêvait un peu en panique et messieurs
j'imagine qu'ils quant aux que fasse
autre chose juste pour floch et sa tête
ouais mais je dirais que peu importe que
tu as games et professionnelle le pôle
site souhaite que deux secondes après
que ça marche
une game c'est vraiment pas bon se
déconnecter une à deux ans
sommet et fait que non qui était jouée
tout nuit ou que tu es juste deux entre
hazard et ses grands parents puis moi je
lui même la pitié j'ai pas capable de
deux ans passés c'est très simple
arnaque bouton sciages c'est comme genre
est une fraction de seconde c'est
tellement rapide le cigre amendes et des
réflexes le jeu de réflexe le corps d'un
homme s agit de la courbe de crs 45 tu
peux avoir tellement d'émotion le tigre
qui ne sert pas des faits que c'est
vraiment un des jeux les jeux truqués
les plus belles courbes le jockey
poursuivre des suites facture puis des
jeux de congolais qui ont apparaît
sensiblement le même timing mais sinon
tu sais beaucoup plus c'est vraiment
rapide sur un puits k2 fini de jouer
têtus comme genre fatigué vidéo teaser
quand même que fait sentir dans ton
corps paraît que ça dépasse c'est
vraiment comment je suis embarqué dans
la pratique c'est ma forme pour
entretenir ma pratique et si ça se passe
bien aussi c'est je le sent moins la
fatigue et si ça se passe très mal
un gagnant jusqu'à 15 c à perdre en
ligne le temps mais c'est perdre aussi
de savoir comment perdre que je pense
quitte une des choses les plus
importantes la compétition sportive et
ou de jeux vidéo savoir comment père
depuis peu chez cd copiés et distrayant
mais apprendre des comportements corps
qu'on remarque
la cote ces switchs gang soit après
s'était jamais perdre un enfant mais la
plupart du temps les gens
et c'est c'ui grand que lui permet il
perd 2,99 points pour son staff avec moi
j'essaie d'apprendre chaque défaite mais
j'ai l'impression que ces gens allaient
maintenant les gens que nous on côtoie
en ligne quand kong
richer c'est pas le monde qui se rendent
dans le 001 pour ça que twilight dans le
fond ou des normes avec un rythme élevé
ces des nôtres qui ont joué beaucoup qui
sont rendus dans un niveau de ses
provisions
mais quand même comme dans tout jeu ray
les jeux
un jeu compétitif pour moi si j'étais
quand j'étais games développeur qui me
désole
le but de ce drame damas l'alternance
critique de joueurs qui prime a pourri à
ton jeu c'est leur faire croire qu'ils
sont bons avec les autres peu importe
leur niveau quand il joue même s'ils
jouent dans le plus beau niveau le seul
voeu d'un coach en bronze dans les
autres ligues pense que c'est l'ego de
rembrandt soit clairement pour y sauter
france
ces vers sont bons c'est super important
parce que ça fait qu'ils étaient joueurs
iraient si juive mais est-ce qu'un
mauvais côté c'est que ça par an chez
pas candidat mais on n'a pas travaillé
sur la toxicité d'un jeu vidéo puis on
commence à se rendre compte que je sache
et achille pour les nouveaux joueurs et
on arrivait dans une communauté qui
traite de est ici c'est vraiment un truc
comme l'autre jour mon copain ils jouent
à compter chaque mail dépouillé pas
aussi bon que moi pendant tout le jeu
vraiment des ligues plus boys pour le
fun puis l'autre joueur mondial si je
pense que j'apprenne père de gameblog
embarque ce mardi péter joue pour moi là
bas on voulait faire une touche une joke
les stages durant gérard barc pis
ça fait même pas c'est qu'ils jouent
dans une ligue de calibre de mercredi vu
comme bien meilleur que subit le goût
qu'on s'inscrit à presque chaque fois
que tu fais dans ma tête je me dis
qu'ils apprennent à mon calibre est
convaincu que j'ai pas fait mais le game
écrit après je gagne la ronde petit juge
kato qui je me dis mais crime le gorille
est tellement inconscient de ce qui ne
va pas il y avait tellement d une grande
envie qu'eux
lui qui après ou à l'abbaye regarde son
écran écrit après le monde que c'est
l'alpha jet phare de quoi qu'ils étaient
comme vraiment
puis-je expliqué je mange je mens jamais
les débuts à part été hautement de rue
saint jean à penser que c'est le monde
qui sont bien avec mambo et non mais
c'est en même temps j
moi j'ai déjà connu du monde quittait
même juste son internet oscille way et
que ça se peut très bien
souhaitons pour russe ce que ça mange
internet ça lui permettait de filippi
ils ferment leur aujourd'hui ils sont
crampé d'avorter il ya tellement
n'importe quoi le jeu comme puis
surprise le serveur que le kung fu phare
de quoi c'est déjà partir quand j'en
parle c'est une nounou d'enfer
ouais huées
je pense que ça va être l'étape la plus
importante c'est les prochaines
générations qui nous ont soit conscient
que c'est de la merde et pas juste faire
c'est la marque fait sembler assez
costaud mais gens faire la différence
ouais et du qui nous en faire comme fou
qui si jamais le vous aurez remarqué sur
un d'aller développer des jeux ou
travailler sur twitter facebook ou vous
fait une différence
votre communauté à vous qui sur vos
enfants c'est ce qu'on peut faire le lit
et si on n'a pas l'argent les ressources
qui en parlez moi j'en parle le plus
possible il faut changer quelque chose
un système d'éducation il faut ça aucun
sens le quai nous professeurs sont peu
outillés pour apprendre aux jeunes
paris doit apprendre quoi pour
comprendre les réalités du gaming du web
puis comment et comme interagir en ligne
socialement avec les autres ok comment
recevoir un message parce que des fois
les messages qu'on reçoit ils nous font
vraiment mal alors que c'est comment
envoyer un message passe des fois même
pas volontairement tu veux dire à quelqu
un quelque chose qui fait que cette
personne ne peut vraiment le prendre mal
mais tout le dit avec des bonnes
intentions dans la vraie vie c'est
beaucoup plus facile que j'aimerais ça à
personne si je dis quelque chose de
votre marché et j'adore ce qu'ils me
disent quelque chose mais on va faire
d'autres choses que tu peux à l'archet
et kanté qui sera toutefois moins trois
quarts 15 en deux secondes on a des
personnes différentes parties normand
excès ces interactions l'eau moi j'ai
été élevée comme tu dit si je passe du
coup les pourcentages mais c'est 80% des
interactions entre humains qui sont dans
le non verbal le soupçon de judo fij
irec apparemment j'ai lu les staps
dans un article
cette année en 2018 apparemment montréal
personnes sortent d'eux un adolescent
présentement c'est fou comprendre quoi
parce que tu mets ton mouche game
vraiment de temps en temps le risque est
quand même rare jour par d'autres
je me fais traiter de fer got puis 2 et
world à chaque fois si vraiment shaq fu
la game et ouais non mais le ramasser
fois qu'ikea on utilise encore ces mots
le temps
on a fait un podcast avec un goal
s'appelle nicolas ouellet tandis que
sonnaient moteur pinoit au petit toute
nudité était catégorique le 9e used and
world le tien mais c'est encore
tellement fréquent dans le gaming pris
comme une insulte qui est tout le monde
se lance bille target aussi on dirait
que c'est laid la place où c'est le plus
long ou ce que c'est et évolution de la
pensée et sera mais faut savoir que les
gays bis et universel qui est c'est pas
comme si on allait voir une partie d'or
qui se rassemblent des gens qui trip hop
qui fait que c'est sûr que c'est plus
site fashion il reste toutefois si je
prends juste les états unis paraît non
je prends juste 2 me imagine
tu peux aller chercher quelqu'un super
fin fond de choupo suprême nec qui tique
que lui dans sa vie il y était rangée
avec que des blancs ou que des pilles
dix ans puis ses parents sont
extrêmement raciste
il vise le no1
parce que pour lui ça lui c'est comme
ceux qui étaient trois programmes clés
gaming mènerai avec les interactions en
ligne d'ici peu plus de l'épître
frontières yapi distance et plus dé et
conséquences mais dernièrement dans la
seine d'auteuil à un incident ou est ce
qui est un joueur de l'équipe
professionnelle qui a eu des propos
racistes comme appli est une équipe de
chinois je pense qu'ils ont comme appli
ching trang puis c'est lui le comédien
un peu une blague qui est sympa pas
c'est pas tout je me suis tu as vu sa
passe et noms mais je suis dans le match
si c'est arrivé dans ma faible des piles
joueurs étaient bannies
oui exact ça peut passer par toutes les
joueurs chemin ils ont une sanction puis
[Musique]
faisait une blague c'est un peu la
culture du gaming qui la réponse de
l'instance qui est sanctionné dans la
bouche et qui s'est justement
justement parce que c'est dans la
culture du gaming qu'il faut arrêter
d'accepter sortie puis ce mois quand
j'ai vu ça j'ai été agréablement surpris
de voir qu'ils avaient des mesures qui
avaient été prises pour pour essayer
d'aller dans bonne direction dans ce
sens là parce que si tu vois ses joueurs
de la porte des joueurs qui restent des
joueurs qui t'écoutent le game et puis
qui qui eux aspirent à les leur même
s'ils se rendront jamais probablement
métier mais un jour devoir probablement
des joueurs professionnels se faire
sanctionner pour des propos comme
ceux-là peut-être sans faire un chemin
dans leur tête
j'espère j'espère moi aussi si ce n'est
ce pas ça être un pas dans la bonne
direction parce que l'éthique si
l'esprit sportif l'exemple ont accès
quelque chose qui est plus établis sud
dans le sport et des affaires qui se
passe aussi mes autres équipes peut-être
que le respect des adversaires mais un
haut niveau ça doit être vraiment moins
toxique qui a un niveau tout à tcc à
l'hôtel plus respectueux oui basket des
organisations à des mets de l'argent
jositsch commencera pas à traiter le
monde de tout le monde est contre
d'arrêt contre eux disent que tu peux
pas faire ce qu'elle fit dans un bain
sanctionné par la communauté netbook
même père de l'argenté deux ans est
passé aussi
m
et heureusement que ça n'arrive pas tous
les jours mais ça répare un haut niveau
je dirais que c'est juste pottas et
fouquet le toit dans le fond tu joues
avec canto logic gaming leur division
emeline puis est-ce que mettons vraiment
avant que l'avènement d' twitch et tout
et tout et tout j'imagine que les
constructeurs avec les équipes c'est un
peu ce qui permet de vives et je dirais
là
avant en fait ça m'a jamais vraiment
permis de vivre parce que tu régime sauf
quand je dois juste content du gaming
pilote quand je débute fulton et je vais
contrôler gic mais je vais tellement
plein d'autres petites robes
commanditaires génie propre event génie
propre aux apparences il m'est encore
maintenant quand encore que le petit
peuple kontrast on tond chemin
chronologiquement de steam et ont au
moins su avait dit à mes parents
le jeu phare full time gaming j'avais eu
un mérite attention
j'aurai une intervention c'est
premièrement s'arrêter non tu fais pas
ça mais après ça n'est donc s'arrêter
oui comme ça a été encore à toi
j'aurais eu un long chemin à démerder
comme je pouvais le tir avant que ça
commence à être payant parce que
maintenant il y en a qui sont
millionnaires le tice on le sait
maintenant sauf que ça fait pas dix ans
et il y en a qui gagnent bien leur vie
avec sopi même si en a qui dernière vix
s'est tu gagnes le chargeur du monde une
fois pilote est correct avant ses yeux
je suis moins fort le team est donc au
recul toi quand tu as pris la décision
de faire ce fauteuil mme qu'elle a été
mais dont les étapes de ta carrière
jusqu'à être professionnellement 100%
photos mes notes et je dirais que avant
que je fais c'est faux le thème je fais
à temps partiel poche et c'est de faire
le plus dans toutes les classes ou des
vidéos du streaming puis moment donné je
me suis dit qu'il le sujet messti full
time d'argent parce que j'en fait déjà
un peu ça comité
je fais le saut parce que je pense que
je t'aurais mais bon je pense que je
ferais que c'était vraiment pas
équivalent à ce que je faisais chez
ubisoft
ouais même espèce de jeu là c'est que je
prends le drop de salaire de 15 25 ans
pour ça mais ça va être que ray pour
être capable de vivre en faisant je suis
d'accord avec toi sostéo qui parce que
moi j'ai toujours été comme ça j'ai
jamais vraiment à l'argent j'ai toujours
été aux expériences et et même quand je
rentrais chez ubi au début j ml par
année le tessin n'a aucun sens c'est pas
grave parce que moi je voulais trop bien
je veux des hôtes et c'est la même même
si j'avais une archi tout un par jeu
vidéo kit constat star avait bien ok je
m'en fous pas que ça a été la même chose
quand il fallait que je saute s'étaient
battus par tel ou tel avantage sur beat
par et d'expérience ces petites vacances
est jetée gérer des actions en compagnie
de ce jeu parts ou actions à ubisoft
après la décision consciente de quitter
hudson j'avais décision je dois prendre
un besoin libye était vraiment très cool
et m'ont dit j'ai dit je pars dans ma le
web parce que je peux pas
main sabbatique si ça marche pas je
reviens dit ok go au fait que je suis
parti un an
et puis après un an j'ai dit je suis pas
encore survenir mondiaux qui berne de
notre six mois et que moi j'étais
arrivée va aider pendant ce temps un an
et demi le puits après six mois je dire
qu'ils n'ont jamais un pas
et j'ai vu que j'étais capable de faire
dit d'après moi ça va aller en
augmentant
l'autre source de revenus à ce moment
lui c'était c'était sur le streaming
avec twitch ne sut jamais salaire de mon
équipe une équipe mais c'était beaucoup
de spectateurs que ce match je dirais
deux tiers mon équipe un tir primé qui
le 1/5 mon équipe pécresse ce que je
fais le on commence avec qui mon équipe
dans le fond on était acheté parce que
moi quand j'ai vendu mon équipe counter
logic
j'avais mon équipe à moi on a vendu
notre équipe comme trop logique après ça
dans ce jeu devenu employé puis le côté
magique s'est fait acheter par les
groupes extrémistes a tout changé ici
encore c'est que moi je suis devenu
employé es joueurs professionnels comme
un joueur de rugby ou des facultés et je
vais les mêmes contrôles que d'autres et
que ça encore tout changer même contre
le contrôle mais les mêmes contre au
niveau des règles pourcentage équivalent
à nous tous et que ça a changé quand
même pas mal à faire poussivement et
négativement je récuse ça a été beaucoup
plus positif que négatif sur le net il
ya des choses dans le sport qui était
comme par exemple si tu te recommande
par personnel l'équipe d'or qui prend un
gros pourcentage encore un billet mais
le sinaï avait effectué
c'est intéressant de voir comment kaige
des choses que j'aime pas dans le sport
qui fait que tu aies wells aussi
d'arriver est-ce que c'est grave pour
moi non l oxygène quand même un grand
fair personnel du camp va plus à voir
même si j'en donne est par contre pour
les restes étaient multiples et si elle
dit on vraiment le meilleur depuis qu'
on a eu de la chance ça c'est quelque
chose qui se passe de plus en plus
hachée que dans dota et paris saint
germain qui est une équipe de soccer
professionnel française qui ont
je pense acheter une partie de l -g dit
gainey playa psg lg dit fait que c'est
comme une équipe chinoise mais qui
brenda paris saint germain qui est une
équipe qui vaut des milliards de lors de
ce câble de football en france
l'excès c'est quelque chose qui arrive
de plus en plus qu est ce que tu vois
une tendance que ça va continuer en ce
sens oui je pense que les autres
attaques qui organisation ils sont
soumis saturées qui le canadien de
montréal
il va pas échanger plus de femmes que
doucement avec le en achetaient n'est
que sortir une équipe de gaming pour 11
à vous et moi c'est pas si cher que cela
soit 5,6 et ils peuvent ago grossir
leurs fans boys et augmente rapidement
et ceci je te dirais que toutes les
grosses équipes rendements se sont fait
acheter par huawei soient achetés se
rendit des partenariats lyon départ d'un
rêveur mais et tous deux nient le c'est
très rare en fait je pense qu'ils ont
tout jeté
que ce soit clair manly colonna c'est
avec qui mais c'est peut-être la seule
parce que oignons lardons l'art de gérer
leurs affaires pas mal est peut-être la
seule et même liquid e
et
optique même optique car si optique ce
qui fait des partenariats maintenant
avec des équipes souvent de basket
j'ai pas pourquoi le basque est triple
il ya beaucoup de parents rien avec les
baskets et un effet l'un peut presque
paddock y toutes mes sacs aux comptes
avec les messieurs fillon du basket
aussi nécessaire mais pas ceux qui
consultent et sauve que parce qu'avec la
nationale chaque équipe de hockey pour
l'année prochaine pour 16 ans il fallait
key tui initial équipiers ont fait ce
qu'ils ont fait avec touquet en fait ça
avec le b elle est parti c'était une
année est serrée en fait je pense qu'il
y avait huit équipes qui étaient obligés
d'avoir un joueur professionnel à tous
qui le jeu l'ennemi tout cas je dis et
sa partenaire chacune des équipes mais
était identique ligue de basketball en
ligne et puis je pense qu'ils la même
chose interloire vista mu arrive ça me
avec inutile de chaque équipe doit
bourgeois il
je sais qu'il ya un joueur professionnel
et fifo alain pack qui fait partie
l'impact mais c'est vraiment pas
médiatisé mais mon contact est ici pour
un joueur de l'impact un joueur de
l'histoire
ouais il joua fut formé kisimba regard
de l'impact de mort et ouais c'est ça
parce qu'ils m'ont m'ont demandé ils ont
fait une journée genre impact
technologies gaming sais pas quoi ils
m'ont dit reviens rencontrer notre
joueur professionnel des cheveux et puis
j'ai pas pu y aller malheureusement fait
que j'en sais pas vraiment entendu
parler j'étais vraiment surpris je vois
où l'impact qu'un joueur professionnel
de jamais entendu parler ainsi mieux
peut-être les compagnies qui font se
mettant dans le but d' expédient leurs
femmes baisser si on prend admettons
qu'on prend l'exemple du canadien de
montréal qui achètent une compagnie de
xp intime de ea sports québec
ils font ce mais ici ils s'en vantent
pas pour pau nuire à l'image
dès leurs fans qui ont des jeux d'été de
hardcore fans de rock et qui apprennent
quelqu'un vienne maria la jeune équipe
de gaming à cause des préjugés que e.on
probablement qu'ils vont voir ce
négativement comme nouvelle mais ça se
peut us jay kay montréal c'est vraiment
une franchise qui différente de tout
leur jeu puisque exemple ont emprunté
les relations chine et achetées
complexité parce qu'ils en parlent ils
sont ce qui mine les cowboys de dallas
tout ok - les seahawks trimming à chaque
fois que les gros joueurs qui viennent
de la région de portland ou diallo vont
voir les games ou twitter google et fac
et je pense qu'il ya des légendes il dit
les compagnies et certaines franchises
qui sont plus wheeling moi et moi je
pense que ben oui faut qu'ils s'en
foutent un peu de ce qui sépare le
négatif aux autres wolfach veulent aller
de l'avant
j'ai l'impression que peut-être dans le
public aussi dans l'oeil du public
c'est moins marginalisée qu'avant gaming
certaine époque les premières fois qui
avait fugué milliar ds le monde cholet
serait pas de bon sens que ça fait le
spo dise pas maintenant c'est normal tu
fais je faisais beaucoup de pêche geof
moi je faisais beaucoup de villages dans
la même catégorie que les blogs et les
autres joies sont les cds pisser sur
facebook c'est comme acquis ses bons
coups du sommet c'est pas du sport c'est
moins pire que maintenant sur l'iss les
cds c'est ça vole jamais très nous on
avait fait une recette pour le super
bowl années passées c'est une recette de
dell dell de chou fleur dans le fond
c'est comme une recette de poulet mais
sans viande pions on s'était fait joli
rda savait pas publier ça sur facebook
le savez tcs avait été dès les
commentaires les plus belles genre
c'était juste du monde qui disait as tu
gagnes de vegan qui se noie paix avec là
on va continuer à manger le poulet pour
le super bowl et stipulant que je suis
quand même des moggi de personnes qui
vaut mieux car notre à cette époque
c'est pas bon mais je pense que là à
plus tôt ne veut pas les fans de foot
c'était les derniers vont devenir les
oui justement à cause que tu vaux l'eau
ou est ce qui est le plus attendu qu'une
brique mais en même temps c'est quand tu
le fais ça revient un petit peu ce que
tu disais tout à l'heure de capable de
recevoir les commentaires sur les
réseaux sociaux
quand tu reçois les commentaires c'est
que mme ok t'es capable de bien les
recevoir de lire ses commentaires là de
faire c'est quoi cela dérange pas
vraiment pas ce que promet que ceux qui
ont vu leurs recettes qui sont dit je
vais la faire pour le super bowl
ces programmes pour ceux qui ont
commencé ce qu'est non sans mal peut ici
se sentent 500 mails et puis on dit moi
j'essayais cd ouailles eu notification
de personnes ça m'arrivera marqué dans
une bataille demain mais j'ai choisi le
duo jamais quand ça compte piscine ont
appelé le fils tu veux jamais m ont
commencé à augmenter pas mener j'espère
bon mais j'ai fini tu sais pas c'est
quoi le pourcentage est passé mais on
fait quoi
[Musique]
traduit par les deux types c'était
disait qu'après trop bruit place même si
à 9 22 ou 35 il rien qui va être dit
qu'il va avoir un impact sur l'opinion
des personnes soient taxés comme après
trop après ce après trop me placer comme
terminée ça ira pas plus loin
suivant
car on a pu savoir sol et je trouve
qu'au québec on est très avoir là dessus
mais à moi je serai quand même beaucoup
politique
j'ai mes amis que ça implique beaucoup
sont les équipes au jeu
ils m'envoient des enfants des pays
qu'ils ont ici mes amis vont réécrire à
la mort mon point de vue une belle
opinion mais c'est quand je regarde à
coucher parce qu'il est pauvre on part
avec le pharmacien ya justement est venu
sur le podcast puis lui dit qui a pris
comme mission de répondre à 100% du
monde mais pourquoi j'ai fait ça je sais
pas lui qui est un peu c'est comme ces
sujets son son compte reverser une
soirée face aux aces qui y attaquent des
limites des momies de la santé vers la
science puis petit quand attaquer quand
sur quelque chose qui croît depuis qu'il
est tout petit il va pas accepter
facilement délaissé son pointu mais lui
a décidé de répondre à tout le monde je
sais pas pourquoi ils simplifient sont
nécessairement juste pas de problème par
intégrité parce qu'il ya dit qu'elle est
forte puisque sa conclusion dès que de
répondre à tout le monde ça donne si
j'écoute je ne sais pas ce que ça donne
son crochet d'engagement à 100% sur
facebook mais ce n'est que la porte
automatique son facebook touche ici
parce que nous pensons qu'un mois et
saufs au kings les gens
je réponds pas si je peux le dire mais
non pas que j'envoie un message
automatique qui dit merci de
de m'encourager en anglais merci
m'encourager si c'est très important je
vais répondre rapidement
sinon je peux pas répondre à tout le
monde merci qui dès que c'est important
mais j'en voyais mal donc mais ce sera
pour sa thématique pour moi parlons-en
d'autres imaginent qu étant une femme
dans gaming tu te mettais sujettes à ce
que tu le veuilles ou partie des dégâts
un petit peu gêné introverti en vraie
vie qui décrivent en ligne parce qu il
connecte avec toi par leur passion pour
le gaming recevoir beaucoup ça va être
vraiment pour les femmes bonne nouvelle
pour toi mais c'est les smart pour les
25 ans le 3 4 ans que même dans les
tournois tout le monde connaît
maintenant litiges plus humide ou je
sais pas mais mais encore
c'est une fille que quand tu étais une
fille dans le domaine du jeu vidéo ça
peut m'arriver gaming ce qu'il ya juste
ouaki et le sud ouest est littéralement
jambon puis moi c'était comme une merde
répond c'était vraiment sympa mhc quitté
le moins crue possible
12 13 ans quand même ce qui est bon
c'est peut-être aussi que moi je
recherche plus souvent taper quelqu'un
j'ai pu le jumpy la même vibe et puis je
l'aï trop dit elle je m'en foutais
c'était aussi donné un répit et mais ça
arrive pas mal moins 32 ans dans la vie
ces jeunes dans le monde du gaming est
ce que ces vieux ouyahia je pense que je
les applique
abonné aux gars qu'ils sont plus chez
les gars savent comme d'un côté ce qu'on
annule joueurs professionnels encore qui
s'appelle taz qui peut les gagner et qui
ont mon âge qui passera aussi que nous
avons à jeudi le temps pluvieux et ayant
dit qu'ils sont déjà plus avancé dans un
sens oui on n'a pas beaucoup plu je
dirais que moi la raison pourquoi juste
encore le sait vraiment pas pure passion
parce que je n'aime pas vraiment gevrey
plus d'argent si je t'ai vu jouer speech
impliqués autrement et c'est juste que
je me dis moi j'ai d'un jeu mais plus
qu'un autre mais plutôt parce que je
passe à côté du bateau le cahier des
gens qui sont un élève alors que c'était
moi je me suis jamais plus de temps de
jeu il y avait quatre à menchov
en ce moment il est multi multi
millionnaire la cfu le lupus et east
wing et mes mots je connais pas fallu
cette fois ci est une joie si instant
ils jouaient a commencé hello hello
premier s'est vraiment démarqué que lui
l'a pas volé ce qui est du las dos et
qu'on peut fouiller chez dc pour la
belgique est streamé quasiment tous les
jours pendant 7 8 heures avant de
devenir une bise grenier pied bon art
genre tous les jeux il ya des
professionnels adjoints diwan pendant
qu'ils étaient professionnels et l'eau y
gagne un tournoi dans les deux jeux puis
et l'ossétie du sud équipe le fait qu'il
fallait qu'ils prévoient qu'il
randonnait pourquoi il fait
il fait ce qu'il veut mais qui lui est
vraiment castrés mais vraiment
intéressant pour les jeunes et pour les
jeunes même s'ils sommes un peu un james
it up c'est vraiment au tpiy
ils étaient les gènes se retrouve
beaucoup dans lui parce que c'est aussi
encore un peu kido et de gilles stream
12 heures par jour fait que j'aime le
matin puis bon si des gens veulent la
prendre de limoger trait de génie
je trouvais d'autres mines avant il
travaille fort il ya bien des heureux
kraft pourrait exploser bail était le
leur
parce que là il ya pas de covered by
quasi pu pro la base même s'il fait plus
de tournois et compétitions spéciales
s'est pas vraiment les tournois les
tournées très atypique l'espèce discours
belge avec élites du monde qui donne
l'argent pour les positions que c'est un
peu un peu différent c'est pas dit vrai
vrai vrai tournoi comme avant nous mais
on aime allier partout kitty et éviter
aux teen choice awards c'est comme de
bonassama à cause de son talent sombre n
est ce que c'est possible d'être dans
l'étape les yeux d'un jeu
ce que je peux remonter à un niveau pour
traquer le fond oui tarifs d'art
il ya des gens qui sont juste des dieux
du toit mais tant qu'un toujours bête
seydoux a joué à fahrenheit temps en
temps pour le fun se voit déjà joué à
fond mais qui piqua j'ai fini ma soeur
de jeu par jour j'aime chez toi qui m'as
bien je vis tard deux jours après le
présentement c'est le jeu qu'il peut
jouer sa planète je pense que des pistes
puissent et autres comme vous j'attends
juste parler de force d'être partout je
présente un phénomène qu'on ait jamais
joué
mais ce qui était peut-être tenté deux
fois de dire je fais tout le souhait de
voir un nouveau jour parce que toi
maintenant on s'entend que le streaming
sur twitch c'est une façon de faire des
bons revenus et moi j'assume même plus
pour un revenu parce que j'en fais plus
de revenus que je fume pas ouais c'est
ça y est on sait qu est ce qui vient
avant tout essayer
- probablement pourquoi je vais
recommencer schumi pour que je me suis
mis de suite après comment régissent le
sait que je veux cadastre mettre en jeu
ma communauté
c'est la femme qui est la plus spéciale
pour les gendarmes étaient streamés it e
ils peuvent vraiment être avec toi à
prendre soin de ta vie que je fasse du
tout bien ça grimpe tout facebook tahrir
à voir je suis mis au niveau de la
collection lancée le mook chercher à
maximiser la connexion avec mes fans
sont là des femmes des fois c'est
justement les amis ou des gens qu'ils
connaissent ou peu importe le monde trip
à interagir au regard d'un swing moi
j'écoute un peu comme les podcasts c'est
d'avoir un long moment il n'était rompu
que tu es juste naturel
ouais moi j'aï sans regarder déçu je
suis vraiment dans ma main par manish
j'aime beaucoup regarder sur et je
trouve que c'est trop des listes dites
il ya beaucoup de monde ils mettent
leurs schémas côté hippie qui font
douter c'est comme ça que je fais ouais
mais m'ont jamais fait que ce chèque est
déçu et richard ont préféré sa grosse
téléphone portable mais chardy total
l'été est souvent une boiterie l'epad et
instagram demonchy [ __ ] c'est la bonne
chose c'est vraiment mon jeune trip sur
fade
ses saillies c'est un super bon gamer
est ok mais moi je regarde pas compromis
qui ont découvert des as un matin puis
quand lui c'est un peu une chose que je
puis la leçon et peut maintenant parce
que ce que j'aime mais ton avec le
stream et c'est que en fait dans ma vie
que soit le support ou dans toutes les
autres facile de ma vie ce que j'aime
vraiment beaucoup c'est les storylines
d'outils permettant de suivre une
histoire dans un tournoi maintenant de
savoir que tel joueur était avec
l'équipe avant que le est rendue dans
une autre équipe qui joue un conte
claude cpie de sisters in line up avec
les stream
j'ai l'impression que ça rend les
joueurs
plus supporter les attachant l'exemple
que j'essaie ortiz île qui est un joueur
de dota 2 qui joue pour yves raude
geniuses puis lui en truquant son stream
juste pour la personne qui était parce
qu'il est au naturel de façon stream
pays poteau le teint glory tepa de temps
glorieux le spo total et les meilleurs
jeux qui fait pitié des fois et c'est
quand j'étais juste à l'instant son
stream 2 comment lui était c'est devenu
mon joueur préféré
là j'ai un attachement à son équipe il
peut importe l'équipe avec laquelle il
va être le tir je vais prendre pour lui
ça fait quand j'écoute des tournois je
suis vraiment investi c'est dans ces
affaires-là non mais c'est vrai ça fait
que ça fait que je suis une storyline
pense que met-on
c'est rare le monde je reprends
l'exemple du rock et ses rangs le monde
qui sont des fans de hockey qui pourrait
coûter une game des highlanders contre
les devils avec autant d'intérêt qu'une
gaine de son équipe préférée que
n'importe qui d'autre
faudrait que les athlètes ce fut leur
entraînement by sap sap ou rem et il ya
des équipes qui commencent à faire sur
les espèces de documentaires sur les
joueurs sauf que
mais dans quatre jeux prend pour
quelqu'un sait vraiment plus fort a
suivi m
moi c'est comme ça que je pense qu'ils
me lacoeuilhe notice et sa conjointe
audrey qu'ils se sentent déconnectés
qu'en football
80 c'est partout dans le monde
pourtant ils ont eu l'impression que
j'ai rien fait depuis six mois passé
industries mhi du tombeau du sud c'est
vraiment la raison pour que je veux
recommencer à ce prix mais parce que je
veux refaire partie de leur vie
j'aimerais me qui rien apprendre à me
connaître comme synonyme dé quoi que
j'aime bien sûr que j'aimerais voir de
quoi puis je me suis faille ce type i je
veux je suis capable de parler d'être
comme ça dans mesrine parce que le saf
estimant commentant par des canaux des
entrevues des trucs aux choses sérieuses
mais dans laquelle on était le plus
naturel
tu peux pas être un personnage vraiment
la raison pourquoi je recommence et puis
c'est pour ça que j'ai pris 0 contre eux
en décembre cette année que je veux
recommencer à jouer sur unibet j'ai pris
aussi 25 livres ont travaillé toute la
nuit fait que je veux recommencer à
m'entraîner tous les jours le temps sa
route 80 vols par annie ce que tu en
manges du junk food d'aéroport
malheureusement c'est vraiment super des
fois comme ça des journées de 15 ans
vont pas dans son quart de travail
non ce ne soit pas un tr min soit 4 po
parce que tellement tu as besoin
d'énergie fictives ou ainsi s'agit quand
même pris beaucoup de poids qui touche
tout genre à me faire dire ouvertement
sur une piste quand j'embarque jeu comme
la wii
j'ai pris du poids négatif
non seulement de date mais c'est
vraiment ça j'ai le record
j'ai pris décembre las à la fois que
j'en ai semble j'ai deux tournages le
premier pit et à date le dha petit
déclic et non avec la famille le chien
le stream les l'entraînement et que
c'est ça mon budget est encore plus
parce que j'ai refusé at on est obligé
enchaîne j'ai refusé parce qu'arrêter
possibilité pour moi de berne charles
pictet pays peut-être que je serai amené
à abandonner ce texte qui n'accepte
jamais ce temps lutz et ça arrivera
jamais parce qu'il va toujours avoir
quelque chose d'autre sa première fois
depuis 4 ans le case ih que je me prends
un mois c'est même pas un mode off le
jeu va travailler les mains jusqu'à je
veux rester à au québec
déjà le c'est vraiment difficile de
commutation des affaires à toronto ça
arrive tout juste au québec puis enjoy
le monde vous conduisez pas parce qu'un
nouveau set up de j'ai même pas plat
guimond mon manque encore de down au
caté jamais chez toi est chez soi c'est
la chose qui fait le plus de bing ses
côtés tout le temps chez toi belem et
enfin un voyage prêt pour sortir de chez
toi pour aller voir ailleurs mais les
vraies vacances quand t'es jamais chez
toi c est chez toi j'ai appris à être
chez moi dans les hôtels
c'est comme ça commence à être moins
pire que ça aurait pris vraiment du
talent à faire comme martin d'hôtel mais
j'en ai tellement fait mais que j'ai
comme pas le choix exmar tonnes d'eau
tels ces deux
2 pouces super ailleurs avec vous je
vous dit en fin de conférence avec un
esprit assure maintenant qu'il retour
sprit arevalo tellabs ordre
c'est à dire non à toute l'efficacité
est déjà dans ma chambre à quatre cinq
heures et demie dans ma chambre d'hôtel
avec mon room service
lorsque ma routine d'hôtel ok ça fait du
bien de connexion d'autres c'est pas
super au canada les connexions ça me
permet de ses pâtisseries mais ça me
permet déjà que des chèques souvent sont
rendus papillon 5
cependant ce qui fait que je peux jouer
à cs le mini là depuis dix mois
puis j'ai commencé à vraiment très très
cool au même match il
ils m'envoient chip mon ordi dans les
hôtels série a pris ses doigts six
heures parce que c'est une tôle d'un
portable via un portable de gaming qui
serait assez bon mais c'est encore plus
collimateur
veut-elle aussi là avec les mains c'est
ok il ne s'est pas tenue ont fait cette
année je le redis m'attend kiwi genre
l'attaqué mythe de sorges pirates au
même
c'est fou ce parce qu'effectivement nous
sommes attendus par en compétition
natation du nord je m'étais besoin de
rester tout le temps t-shirt plus
peut-on entraînement de continuer en
formule 1 mais surtout qu'à mes tongs
les athlètes ils font pas vraiment de
partir souvent de chez eux parce que
c'est chez eux
mais le site et gardanne et on
entretient actuellement une belle façon
de rester chez picard gaming est
tellement d'événements peu de conflit un
peu importe le
en fait ça m'a permis de pouvoir
continuer dans ma team ce parce que
sinon il en fait je fasse des choix qui
arrêtait toute pratique surtout des
commanditaires moi je voulais faire les
deux fait que les conférences permettent
de pratiquer avec une question par
rapport à tour dit que c'était une des
vieilles allemand du gaming est ce que
c'est parce que
six belges vois je vois si je sais je
repasse ou de ma vie fait donc je veux
commencer à mettre ma vie en brandit pas
d'autre chose me trouver et me typhon de
ma famille y avoir un autre job peu trop
où ce parce que le corps humain le
cerveau il ya un pic pic et les
performances de sang tranquillement
entre ce pique nique série 2 ce qui se
passe ce que pendant vraiment longtemps
les pro gamer de mon âge ma génération
qui t'aiment beau on peut pas faire ça
tomberait il ya un peu d'argent se
penser c'est qui la plupart ont raté une
vingtaine de familles
il est ce qu'on voit c'est que ces
gens-là y en a beaucoup qui reviennent
dans le gaming c'est comme crime c'était
vraiment impatient et je peux peut-être
prouve qu est ce que je peux faire le ya
un engouement pour ce marché dont
cnapelinckx en partie non parce qu'ils
étaient plus bon mais parce qu'il
fallait qu'ils vivent avec fasse d'autre
chose qui voulait plus vivre chez leurs
parents où il y avait pas d'argent et
que beaucoup de ceux exposés que les
joueurs des 31 au pot c'est aussi simple
que se préparer à temps plein il vaque à
moins que comme moi tu es vraiment ça
qui fait énormément de choses dans ma
vie pour faire ce à temps plein mais moi
je sais qui il pas mal ça fait quinze
ans que tous les soirs de semaine du
dimanche au jeudi
je ne peux pas sortir c'est comme se
commettre trois semaines par année que
j'ai off c'est trop souvent c'est moi
qui voyage les audi no 9 le mais moi je
pense que que j'ai of la semaine et que
je suis tout le temps en train de guémy
ce sera dur
quatre actions sociales dygalo cinéma
avec des amis et nous sommes compliqués
mais comprend même si la journée est ici
c'est vraiment ce que j'ai fait
énormément de sacrifices
les autres la plupart du monde ment pas
fait mais il est aussi que sigg est
moins bons aussi rapidement puis tu peux
te faire de penser aussi quand je dirais
l'accord mais la coupe c'est exactement
comme le sport et qui sait quoi ses
débuts trentaine que ça commence à
devenir dépendants moi je pense que et
on va avoir de plus en plus des joueurs
vieux
parce que c'est de plus en plus facile
de faire ça te plaît mais comme on en a
parlé au début du podcast c'est quand
même le nombre de tact investi - comptes
pour l'exercice est sûre tous certains
jeux qui te demande pas beaucoup d
expérience dans le sens et les réflexes
plus la mémoire musculaire un an des
jeux d'équipement sont notre sport c'est
l'essence puis laqué me suis comme je
parle c'est clair je pensais à dota
mettant le sillon sur des gars qui ont
des epn de foule donc des actions par
minute de mon gueule mais si du monde
qui qui ont joué puis connaissent les
mécaniques dans d'autres coins du monde
s'est dit évidemment dans chaque équipe
il ya comme deux positions ou est-ce que
celui là faut que ce soit des gaye télé
les mains vraiment quick le messie non
et trois oppositions c'est comme du
monde qui connaissent le jeu est
autrement que leur espérance de vie est
plus est plus avancée mais ça ça m'amène
à une autre question
problème de l'effet de poser souvent
moi mettons dans le sport en général
un pays que moi je connais qui jouent
comme des gaps qui est à haut niveau qui
est capable de battre les kops escalade
dans starcraft 2 c'est quoi les
différences est ce qu'il ya des
différences entre les filles et les gars
que le ciet ce déficit est fait ici est
gay pourquoi est-ce qui est pas un
un match entre les deux plateformes moi
je joue candidats et avec des groupes
toute l'année
ouais ok joui je joue avec l'ina qui
défie mais en jouant pour la fête
jusqu'à croquer les crimes que quand on
joue jamais défilé
on a deux tournois par année de vie ou
d'outreau thomas la coupe du monde et le
web et qui les autres amis avec a86 qui
étaient là ce master en pologne alors
diaby avait une compétition de filles
weck est ailleurs m
quels outils parce que ça fait quatre
ans qu'ils en compétition de fait et
puis il ya les trois seuls que je fais
pas que mon fils aime à la fin de
l'année ont compris que les différences
et en fait il y en a même si c'est juste
du cerveau il y en a des différences
apparemment lego sera meilleure et de
l'orientation nous des réflexes nouveau
l'orientation spatiale ce que je peux
dire au niveau de prendre des décisions
des jurys gagne rapidement
qui vous à voir que la plupart des jeux
compétitifs c'est sûr c'est ce qu'ils
ont besoin donc de base
oui il ya une chance que l'église soit
deux meilleurs jamais jamais eu ça
personnes qui ont jamais joué à des jeux
offensifs il n'y a pas de scientifiques
ça prendrait vraiment un gros
échantillons peut faire ça et mais il y
ait des chances qu'il ya une différence
jacques gros problème c'est vraiment
nouveau de la nombre de filles qui
jouent il y en a compétitive mais en
attendant les champions
les chances qu'il fixe au maire que les
gosses c'est vraiment vraiment vraiment
difficile et puis non seulement c'est
vraiment difficile percée en tant que
femme et c'est agite la toxicité de
l'internet un été s'est prouvé que les
femmes c'est plus débat social puis les
hommes sont plus des souterrains
compétitif et chie dessus direct quand
tu commences sociale qui c'est drôle
mais moi je commence à jacques chirac de
la communauté à cause de l'aspect social
ça a donné que moi j'étais compétitif et
que j'ai en partie dans tout le délire
est vrai que c'est sur la plus grosse
différence mais et
c'est pas le seul drake audi sport
intellectuel il ya pas de ferme le poker
deutsch est noir y a pas de femmes sont
vraiment les mêmes signale t niveau du
compétitif où est extrêmement difficile
pour une femme de faire sa place qui je
pense que ce n'est pas le désir chez les
femmes
de faire ça peut faire cette place là
mais ça arrive et on en connaît m'occupe
des joueuses de poker féminine y en a
vraiment très bonne santé n'est pas
juste j'avais lu un article sur l'humour
aux etats-unis le stand-up qui disait
que pourquoi c'était énormément
difficile pour une femme de fable
stand-up
je trouve que ça se comparer énormément
au gaming
parce que quand une femme commence en
stand-up à ce ramadan harbour qui comme
tous les comédiens et comédiennes en
france élise marre aussi commencé dans
les baux risquent pas leur place peu
importe c'est plus comme c'est
aujourd'hui que youtube terminal temps
c'est beaucoup ce wek est encore parfait
fait qu ils sont chez dessus par les
gosses ou c'est maintenant à puisse à
faire respecter en tant que femme dans
un bar en essayant de faire des jo s'est
énormément tacle il ya beaucoup de
femmes qui arrêtent là c'est qu'ils
veulent peuvent faire le grind et moi je
trouve que c'est quand même très très
similaire sans doute dès qu'ils
commencent à jouer dès que je dis une
phrase d'un jeu que ce soit jacques le
goff tchèque - le gouffre est juste
heinrich que jeune fille legault
mangochie parce que je ne ferais pas
tout traiter différemment que tout ça a
été surtout ta ville
ouais
6e
moi j'ai fais le choix de m'en [ __ ]
mais ça et est encore aujourd'hui très
différemment comprendre qu' on dirait
georges dépôt à subir ce je vais aller
faire autre chose j'aurais été beaucoup
heureuse rapidement dans ma vie mon
cerveau pendant deux ans à peine ce que
je dirai qu'il en coûte
sami ben noir de sony avait passé récent
les dates de dans gaza me ou de la
sérénité de vraiment me sentir heureuse
si je n'ai pas fait ce choix que de me
battre contre les trolls ou compte
effectué nous n'avons pas pu atteindre
ce très rapidement ou beaucoup plus
rapidement ou peut-être pas on sait
jamais et mais comme tu dis le qui sait
le cav qui fait ce choix la conscience
de tout faire dans ma vie j'ai décidé de
me battre pour devenir quelqu'un en jeu
vidéo avec leur chien
je pense que oui si j'aurais bien aimé
si j'aurais déjà dans l'architecturé
encore aujourd'hui fait que j'aurais
pris mon contrat mais moi je sais pas
pourquoi j'ai vraiment ce qui se joue un
père cité des thermes 2018 des pays au
niveau émotif au niveau professionnel au
niveau même mais monétaire mais
c'est nouveau en l'espèce de parier sur
un cheval qui est savais vraiment pas
qu'elle agonise
non moi je le faisais pas repasser
pendant 10 à ma vie je payais pour les
tournois
ouais c'est les tournois situe juste
mettre quatre gangs un tournoi
le chèque temps chacun peut maintenant
je m'en suis toujours sacré je savais
pas si on a fait un tournoi de phi phi
ligue en encaissant 1000 places à 5
les filles de mon équipe et autres
étaient vraiment et we have to oui je
pense à cause de l'argent sachant que
les jeux mois et
m
mouassa richard échanger mes autres ça
change quoi pour les stars nous en
retournent en chine pour ce faire
mais pour ce qu'on veut aussi dans l'île
mais comme moi c'est plus la médaille
d'or pour la france est passé un passé
le sabreur vous avez gagné cinq coupes
du monde organisé différentes équipes et
[Musique]
pilotes
est-ce que tu as un plan de carrière ce
que tu le sais mais tant qu'homme et
dernier encore divulgué mais où je ne
sais pas vraiment et
je te dirai quelle façon et l gendrey ce
serait d'avoir un plan bien
malheureusement moi je vois encore
compétition et ça change tout le temps
tu es c'est comme un sportif et
si je me fais bencherif salle depuis
deux ans je me suis pris une fois je me
suis fait une équipe soi
parti comme chuck se connaissent assez 5
je suis souvent seul ben maintenant à
cause de tout mais voilà tout
le parchemin je reste quand même
présente
est-ce que je vais vouloir être berger
encore longtemps est ce que je me pointe
aux pratiques où est ce que je veux être
sûr noté aussi vouloir transférer vers
un autre autre d'un an et demi est vrai
qu'on a pas que mon agent lui il veut il
veut respecter mes choix mais il veut
que j'arrête de jouer
edit takhar a explosé quand c'est
vraiment est effectif il n'y a pas de
pression du tout et du camp dit prête
est prête mais lui son but c'est que et
hélène à la fois mon agent c'est
l'ancien agent il te disant c'est lui
qui a monté celui qui écrit la première
française qui connaît ce haut niveau de
commun exploser une carole qui le lie à
taches de soleil le 6 heures par jour de
plus à m
et puis le bot pas de restriction à être
de vos pratiques et puis ça bloque ce
qui est en jeu ça c'est quoi ce serait
quoi ça serait de ce fait à jouer à
forza
mais surtout il veut que je m ce que je
me dis merci et et comprenne mes forces
mais qu'on y touche vraiment et il veut
que je sois pause contre eux avec une
équipe parce que il vraiment restreindre
ou de commandes et une totale des
candidats mais ouais c'est pas grave
c'est pas ça qui mais qu'importe
un pass toi tu considères gamers avant
d'être influencé aux moutons à ton ton
arme
et je laisse en fait l'oeuvre le côté la
france on ne fait pas j'aime ce mois
plus que parce que je dois le faire
le physique comme si je faisais quand
c'est propre et encore aujourd'hui mon i
to be pop et bien parce que je
l'entretiens pas comme un vrai français
- foot vidéos youtube pour mes fans
petit soulier quasiment 1000 view the
shack doué encore le pied
je m'appelle sélection puis je perds
quelqu'un pour m'aider parce que moi je
m'en fous que georges investi et qu'elle
m'a dit au monde qui ont suivi depuis le
début souvenirs puis je serai pas en
faire
théâtre villaudric en belgique en jeu
dans un tournoi puis j'aime ça et c'est
la même chose pour moi ça rame j'aime
bien sûr street et j'ai plus d'amis
zarac facebook parce que j'ai
personnellement je sais pas trop comment
[Musique]
ça marche au québec et aérien ok no 2000
comme l'audi qui trippent facebook facs
je fais que je m'ajuste pour le québec
pic du fait qu parce que j'ai aussi fait
tout seul
baverez gg design comme j'ai dit mais
planifié ma cage a beaucoup dit il
enfin puis le dernièrement j'ai vu
toutes avaient animé la soirée avec leur
système temps
c'est quelque chose que tu pensais
peut-être faire un jour d'animation
comme ceux où c'est arrivé vraiment
random et
chercher à cause que c'était une soirée
il veut faire le lien et coups de
couteau trempé moins de les rabaisser
bien trempé moins inquiéter vraiment
renouveler leur lot clientèle mais aussi
jeux s'ouvrir la classica plus de gens
la musique de jeu vidéo en plus tu
essaies de la musique classique c'est
vraiment des mecs comme chez ubisoft 6
et des constats québécois souvent tennis
pas bon compositeur mais que leur seule
tribune leur seul endroit où peuvent
s'exprimer cc ou qui peuvent aussi
gagner de l'argent c'est pas par les
jeux vidéo la musique est incroyable pis
si le musée qui tombe dans l'inconscient
parce que tu es quand tu joues tu
l'écoutés petit activement mais finit
que tu connais les heures
parker à la note près tous les
instruments pts et naked d'aller voir ce
pays de vivre avec un orchestre live
c'est vraiment cool parce que il y avait
trop moi je pensais qu'elle allait avoir
deux personnes logeant les gens qui
crèvent jeu vidéo piégeant qui trippent
musique classique
personne n'y avait des gens qui triment
et musique de jeu vidéo classique pieds
des gens qui paient aucun qui sont venus
pour leur fils leur job n'importe qui
pis crime ne sait que les autres
contribuent le plus à risque et outils
connaissez rien n'est sérieux la musique
c'est arrivé en fait c'était malade
t les jeux ont présenté les images aussi
les prénoms qui ont dit ok je vais
acheter tel je te jure certaine le et
moi j'ai un ami qui jouait pas de temps
que les autres c'est le juge ait donné
la pile des deux assassins des deux
sociétés à cause qui a tripé dans le
concert avec music halle
ok c'était vraiment
c'est vraiment très cool je te très
choyé leur fait et ils ne coopèrent
faire dans ma carrière où j'ai tripé la
gamme de l'ouest qui m'ont dit afin à
tous ceux du triple jeu vidéo
desclaud sociaux pareil qui était
d'habitude et devant une caméra de toute
part d'un public factice de travail
c'est pareil même si game attend que les
gens qui tombent d'habitude être un
acteur tout le temps ça c'est ça c'est
cool pcc c'est justement une des raisons
pourquoi on entend parler de toi tu au
québec c'est parce que tu es capable dé
pas être juste chez vous dans son
ordinateur capable de là tout le monde
en parle puis de bien parler à tout le
monde en parle de bien paraître tout le
monde arabe ceux-ci passent tout le
monde passera par une pierre angulaire
d'un parcours de tout le monde
fonctionnant à part c'est comme ça qu'il
s'est fait au début en plus ma
popularité oui ça existe mais le trentin
et
et je trouve que c'est vrai qu'elle n'a
plus vraiment de m'avoir le cas des
bêtises je pense qu'ils s'identifient
tacle actuel voilà tunis alger parce que
autant plus si j'étais isf gagner par
tous les jours sur 108 où justement
parce que c'est un des premiers à mettre
fin pour son contenu youtube ici je
pense et ils ont mis en bien fait ouais
parce que plus choix le bac on se sait
plus à jour le tpiy j'écoute surtout son
modèle apple c'est qu'à chaque jour ça
donne ça donne aussi bon maintenant la
politique pour un oeil qui équipa
experts ou qui portent bien et que la
gauche pc les démocrates mais c'est
j'écoute aussi positive à marco qui est
aussi très démocrate
en fait c'est les anciens d'obama qui
pensent eux
c'est sûr que moi je suis prêt je parle
ouvertement les otages fait la politique
mais j'avais cette personne mais bon
j'écoute ça m'intéresse beaucoup
jusqu à tous j'ai voulu me donner de
largeur pour supporter la campagne je me
serais content
steed imbéciles des canadiens qui
prennent l'argent des prix là parce que
c'est comme les aidants le même des
livres que j'y mettais drôle d'idée que
j'ai pas à m'impliquer parce que je
trouve qu'on en fait que les amis les
etats-unis ont tellement des packs sur
nous oui que je veux que ça se passe
bien là pour que sa séquence autrement
non c'est que là c'est clair qu'ils sont
encore la première puissance mondiale et
ce malgré que c'est
c'est vraiment spécial ce qui se passe
là pour rester neutres
oui mais on n'a pas souvent tu es bon tu
as une bonne serment nous nos opinions
mais plusieurs toutes nos discussions
sont minimaux ecchymoses d'une île
bizard le même site et républicains et
son bébé s'il voulait qu importe lequel
le web pour ou contre x c'est un
imbécile
il doit être assez des mots sa propre
équipe le jeter au sein des républicains
dans la maison blanche il ya de l'avenir
qu'ils avaient liquidé ses lettres
ouvertes ont dit qu'il y avait parlé à
un journaliste qui disait
dans la maison blanche on était un
intime games à faire partie de la
résistance
on est sûr qu'ils
[Musique]
c'est en tête à ce gain qui dit qui veut
faire n'importe quoi
zo tombe dans un coin pis on y la
nécessaire maîtrise sa belle et rebelle
tc
c'est fun alors deux parties les
républicains sont pas nécessairement
pour moi c'est que vous pas au mal
même s'ils ont des choix sains ou
d'aider les opinions différentes mais
contexte constructif ni consentante mais
la politique est basée la première mois
est une star de télé réalité c'est que
ces colonies le dénoncer mais ceci c'est
paul le nude problème c'est juste que
c'est un déclare marc jeudi à ségolène
est un menteur compulsif le jeu est un
mythomane clairement dit mais il a
l'intelligence de savoir des clubs très
bien connaître les mesures savoir
comment les manipuler ou comment je
pense qu'il façonne un sujet juste parce
qu'ils trouvent cave pour pour savoir
aux riffs il fait juste
parce qu'il veut que ça marche parce que
j'ai tellement ri latule je pense qu'ils
jugent chanceux d'être commis ces faits
qui manipulent les médecins eux-mêmes
stop sans s'en rendre compte il ya
quelques enfants qui fait que quand même
pop il est mais je pense qu'ils
manipulent les gens autour de l'opinion
publique c'est un parti qui dit un
certain niveau c'est un mordu de la
marque puis à même les médias démocrate
qui parlent de cette marche bleue
d'enfants il renforce son message mais
c'est ce qu'il faudrait juste pu parler
de lui on peut pas pu parler lui c'est
le président des états unis a que c'est
complet c'est la raison pour laquelle
qui a été élu parce que c'est tellement
absurde le fait qu'ils se présentent
tous des au début le jeu d'hier sera pas
longtemps en pitié on s'en souvient
ledit président métier vous souvenez les
clients qui se présentent et c'était une
farce comme il ya eu aucune chance que
ce goal le port à part le il sera jamais
président qui
c'est complètement cesse complètement
surréaliste ce présent aujourd'hui
mais ce parce qu'on y est tellement y
est tellement je peux te laisses ta
terme mais atention robe de nom mais
l'est il sait quoi dire pour se mettre
les pieds dans les plats mais ça fait
juste parler de lui pis s'il ya un gars
dans le monde que compris l'expression
par les zambiens parler en mal mais par
les ans c'est lui
puis plus on en parlait même
négativement ça lui donne la légitimité
pour nos lecteurs sont électeurs eux et
c est sceptique d'aimer dieu ou est
méfiant des 10 des médiaux des gros
médias comme cnn ce côté déjà méfiant
playtest gaulle qui dit croyez les
postes et je défèque news et le sahara
force mais cet esprit le
conspirationniste se désunit super fort
qui lui utilise se joue là dessus s'est
renforcé à chaque étape
ces personnes pensaient qu'ils allaient
gagner représenté le participant afin de
penser qu'elles aient gagné les
élections
le joueur je vous demanderais je pense
pas que vous êtes réélu mais des plumes
mais ces chemins après ils ont parlé
tout le monde en partant tôt il parlait
après les élections de novembre
ils ont fait venir deux personnes à
thomas parle pour parler de la politique
américaine qui est en fait j'ai un clip
du gaig et l heure où est-ce qu'ils s
exactement cote parisienne à la télé
si jamais trempé telus le c'était
l'histoire du jeu après la bbc après
après cette époque lui d'ici et élus
genre je dirais invités mois puis si je
fasse des excuses devant tout le monde
puis tu prends l'engagement des plus
jamais commenter la politique et les
midis ségo l'eau au plus aucune chance
d'être élu il fait comme le fait ce
métier pour que
qui décide d'élire un président qui qui
dit une énormité comme celle là peu
importe dans quel contexte et promettons
et à faire j'étais dans ma ville que je
pourrai pas être président c'est vrai
juste pas être président pour des
affaires juteuses à ma vie qui sont
quelque part c'est dangereux
je pense aussi que je pourrais pas que
c'est en fait parce que je m'implique
pas plus parce que je veux pour rester
blanche comme neige
je ne suis pas impliqué dans l'autre
sens je me présente pas mais je veux
faire une série comment je peux faire
effectivement voit plus avec mes idées
mes valeurs avec mon temps avec mon
argent
oui beatty quand une tribune comme tu le
devoir en plus des fluence à faire ce
que d'être présentés être lâche me mets
aussi mais je pense que oui mais quand
même un métier
le mot dit rempl scherwey personnes
détenaient de parler de quelque chose
ici
oui c'est que moi juste part par mon
passé par les trucs que j'ai dit ok il
faut juste quatre ans maintenant ce
maillot du sommet ici un raciste avouer
que je vais donner le défi de ce
programme un agresseur sexuel à vous
papa vous est probablement un misogyne
c'est fini
c'est à dire contre un petit système
juste des paroles
mais il n'y avait pas vraiment d'impact
grave sur la vie direct des gens dans le
vraiment dans le concret ça serait
toujours bien sûr métier les familles
séparées aux frontières titrent de
choses horribles et le travel ban qui
implique vraiment une influence sur la
vie concrète des gens heureux
ces gens là peuvent aussi amener mes
coéquipiers qui est arrivé au pays quand
la verna
elle a jamais eu de papiers à cause que
parent je sais pas trop via la ville
d'accord ça s'appelle comme ça
l'année passée c'était très d'insultés
c'était qu'il ya à peu près un million
de jeunes qui sont en bout de paris dans
les années 90 qui ne sont pas citoyens
américains mais qui on peut le choix
servi par leurs parents qui obama leur
avait donné la cause que dire qu'il y
avait les mêmes droits que dit qu'elle à
avoir les mêmes droits qui est des
citoyens américains qui sont ici depuis
que sous peu il y avait vraiment pour
devenir citoyen américain parce que
l'autre c'est vraiment pas large pour la
photo sont ravis si on veut les renvoyer
dans un pays dont ils parlent même pas
la langue mais parce qu'ils sont pas
unis qui décrit mieux quand c'est là que
fait mon amitié a peut être faire de
tournoi avait peu de chances d'être
pourrait jamais se faire assurer aux
états unis jamais se faire servir
certains marabouts cap et le gros gros
prix et le 11 septembre quand on a vu
que trempe y rester pour déménager à
londres alors qu'il allait 21 heures
jamais et jamais on n'aurait jamais
sorti des olympiques a pas fait
directement c'est pas rien que des
politiques qui ont les politiciens stone
town le monde salue les effets directs
sur la vie des gens on a fait des gros
effet le site son frère et monsieur ni
un à moins qu'elle
moi lui les citoyens et citoyennes sur
des millions et juste lit clé klimov
trinity
il joue sur l'a7 fracture leur petit
lait des familles qui se parle plus
parce que caustique et les chicanes
politiques et d c'est vraiment super dit
viser du monde qui était ami que les
sociétés que pendant les élections c'est
un super pilote ça finissait à
m'engueuler les 4 hommes 10 en a
beaucoup qui gèrent nos présidents ou
des gens qui qui qui ont peau
qu'ils sentent bernés par les élites qui
semble déconnecté qu'ils sauvent tout
d'accord excuser parce que des fois sont
pas tous d'accord qu squeeze mais même
si lui ce texte imprécis dit vrai des
personnes situées est pas un politicien
calanques de bobby de saucisses effet
que pense vraiment pas que tout le monde
qui se portent combine vraiment d'un
croque tout ce qu'il dit mais ça leur
fait du bien parce que quelqu'un qu'ils
leur ressemblent pas ce qui m'énerve le
plus dans politique c'est quand le monde
disent on veut du changement de ça
m'énerve parce que
avoir du changement bravo du changement
ça peut changer la main pour la marde
effectué moi je trouve jamais que faire
du changement c'est nécessairement
positif petit mouton ou oui le monde
voulait du changement avec trompe les
excès quand même au québec où si on
voulait du changement pillent quatre
gardes les deux élections les deux
parties qui sont le plus longtemps on
perd ce diplôme les deux plus nouveau
parti avec celle d'ap la cac en longueur
ni dit qu'un sauvegarde certains
sondages ça montre qu'ils aient beaucoup
de gens qui existait québec soldats ou
cac juste pour le chien on s'attaque ici
sauf que dans le fond le monde voulait
changement plustek sommes qu'un
changement team et
dans la réalité des politiques ça comme
pas de sens d'hésiter entre ces deux
parties le changement puis dans gaming
pour revenir sur ce que tu disais il ya
aussi beaucoup de problèmes de visa aux
états unis avec des joueurs qui viennent
pas des états unis puis c'est à dire
tournant ici tu peux rentrer be mais là
c'est moins pire parce que maintenant
depuis deux ans je savais que tron paris
on est construit comme des joueurs
professionnels disent pas parfait que
les mises au point qu'on appelle tazil
dès que tu peux prouver que tu es
artiste professionnel ton visage est
quand même assez facile à avoir parce
qu'ils veulent des athlètes l'artiste
était le meilleur joueur de shockwave et
le tabac c'est juste
depuis deux ans déjà que ça commence est
plus facile mais il faut quand même pas
faux coptes ont quand même été était
clean un peu l'image est mauvaise on
s'est mis facilement
il a fallu qu'on prouve que je tâcherai
finale après ce cadre je ne sais pas les
plus difficiles et je ne suis pas de
l'art de manas
[Rires]
parce que je suis que shakespeare avec
un joueur pakistanais de d'auteur
justement son frère les deux jeunes
solistes ans puis dernièrement sont pas
en prison aurait pu citer aux états unis
par contre c'est un problème de visa ça
m'amène à une question que je vais te
poser aussi et on est obligé d'avoir un
sobre dans leur équipe
pillon contre performé pudique important
leur top c'est un bon joueur à quel
point ce qu'il est ce que changer une
personne ça change tout acheter c'est
qu'un système danse à 5
je comprends vraiment c'est une danse à
5 le team est quelqu'un que même si
cette danse et professionnellement que
l'époque n'est pas même si tu vu la
sphère des centaines de fois et embarque
le plus pour la première fois il faut
qu'ils la passent ils vont être offre
sortait par amiens lille parce qu'il
veut voir rattraper mais ce sera paul à
la même performance
c'est vraiment ça c'est comme si je
l'avais mieux le c'est vraiment une
danse expression que là avec mon équipe
soeur mais je m'implique énormément
parce que je veux pas que quand
j'embarque dans ce défi se sentent l'âme
est ce normal stéphane joue je suis
quelqu'un joue parce que mes soucis
penser la même chose que pipi 4,4 et
sobre comme ceux
est-ce qu'ils prennent une décision de
forme étant l'auteur hausse le seuil de
5 personnes
[Musique]
le tas de défauts elle n'était
livestream le sais moi mon truc c'est du
pipi ok bah oui à chaque fois que
j'étais youtube le monde comme la
pelouse mais cinq personnes puissent etc
tout est juste un comme étant quelqu'un
est malade d'une journée où quelqu'un
peut d'écourter un petit peu juste quand
c'est la pratique c'est plus de long
terme randonnée 7 1 cette saison si
pendant deux trois semaines une fille
qui fait peu joué parce que air est trop
d'écoles dont je joue et qui le fait
d'être certain elle avait trop d co qui
est bas moi juste à peine pas
transmettre tact et je l'aï joué
beaucoup et c'est plus comme ça que j'ai
embarqué
mais nous on a eu durant l'été une
période où intel 6 août en sauce star
depuis on a eu un moment où le coach et
de ses choix en choisissant la saison
que moi à cause d'eux
tout ce que je fais relégation experts
aujourd'hui nettement il faudrait
paraître tout
mais c'est ce qui se fait que je le sais
c'est ma faute et c'est après ces mots
que je m'implique quand même beaucoup
j'essaie d'être le à quasiment 100% des
pratiques
je donne mes commentaires sur les game
je les regarde mais je travaille plus
avec elle au niveau communication comme
j'ai dit parra clermont but dit parce
que moi je pourrais faire celui-ci amzer
opterait diversité je voudrais devenir
là je vais quand même faire partie de
l'équipe et que j'essaie de plus dire
sur quoi qu'on peut travailler vous et
moi je te laisse et comme j'étais sous
tendent et on devrait faire ce même si
je suis pas en train de jouer
on a toujours joué comme la marque et
c'est comme ça qu'on dit à la presse et
à ses petits est-ce que c'est plutôt des
lits des équipes de filles que de gaulle
à moi je pense que oui
non mais je pensais que ça m'a peut-être
les filles moins impulsive - plein de
hockey je pense qu'on est moins et à
vouloir quitter l'équipe
sinon je change de ton on est plus du
genre à rester et à travailler que nos
problèmes non seulement parce que pour
beaucoup de filles qui jouent fax et eu
beau faire croire qu'ils changent de cap
le retour est beaucoup mais je dirais
qu'au niveau des émotions la façon qu'on
se parle
je pense que de base quand tu travailles
pas tu te parler positivement puisque du
renforcement positif tout le monde
performer mais je pense qu'elle ego en
général ça ramener soit moins compte
c'est moins dramatique dans leur
quotidien si c'est un peu plus rejoint
l'armée tout ce que
une critique négative c'est peut-être
plusieurs de faubourg pour une fille
mais j'aurai quelques enseignes est la
même pour le pays c'est pas mal plus
flagrant dans son comportement kafil peu
qui parce qu'on met aussi
en tant que société on n'exprime plus
son émotion en tant que fille le fait le
modèle qui est un problème souvent j'en
parle je ne regarde pas mais moi je
comme au québec ce temps là il ya un
problème qui la plupart du monde
allemand qui fera comment s'en fout ça
pas tant important mais moi j'aime ce
type ça s'accumule pouvoir par les armes
et y
des fois ça peut ouvrir un méga plus
gros problème puis finalement il est
quasiment autant de gestion de
personnalité que de jeu alors que dans
les équipes de google aient accès à haut
niveau
quand tu veux rester au top le ya
beaucoup de gestion personnalité est ce
que tu peux changer joueurs beats et les
psychologues sportifs qui embarque mais
je dirais qu'à notre niveau qu'on ait
lieu pour échanger l'équipe 2 du travail
ex-cat plus de gestion d'émotion parce
que les équipes mixtes existe waes
existe ne tentera pas par les défis les
équipes mixtes parce que
et nous en tant qu on est comme je suis
pas une dizaine de filles professionnel
en amérique latine tchèque vainqueur
si toi tu veux une chance en tant que
femme pour être meilleurs que nous
jay beagle où ce nom mais on donne porte
crazy kung souvent les filles il y en a
eu beaucoup le t6 total choix là en plus
c'est que tu vois tu peux vivre de
colmar à dyson ou essaient de faire la
différence dans un monde de gramat ça
marchera poule il ya un pas qui font sur
you boys pas de filles qui sont dans les
tout petits l'équipe masculine a compté
chaque nous promettons tu joues contre
les meilleurs go de compétition nous
fait de mourir
et en un contre un contre à
compétitionner dans votre équipe compte
mon avis mais ton et nous on joue contre
des pros des fois dans les
qualifications être comme ce jusqu'en
entend pas parler parce que on sera pas
loin d'un calife et je dirais que
programme un comble un vide que l'on se
démolir mais si tu mets les cinq jours
d'avis que notre équipe dispute sa 6e
semaine fixe au top prague exclu niveau
et huawei haut niveau ski et wyse
mécanique on est proche - niveau genre
équipe
un temps qui dépendront n'est pas proche
parce que c'est encore plus de bras ce
résultat je pense que c'est au niveau
des cantiques des bons joueurs tu te
fais élevé un autre niveau orange qui
nous
si on n'y a ni veau comme à servir le
thé mais pour ne se remet à cette hausse
sur le mois cool
ouais merci d'avoir été là comme agent
1h40 et moins jeunes ont cassé deux
temps forts tels abus mais c'est le tout
trucy en guinée entend bientôt puissante
guillemette a réussi en tant que joueuse
professionnelle telle idée de tête et
par moi je fasse au cje là je loge mais
ton talent chez ta job totalement chez
les bêtes tout en bas car chez toi mon
bac que jamais des ss un fatal à
waldhambach ouais mon profit mon prof
mon oncle est prof d'art sexuellement
non joe klein et j'étais chasselas la
musique est là bas et à quoi qu'elle les
musiques non pourquoi wild at heart 1,2
g chez qui ruse et j'étais chanceuse
parce que même si c'était pas le gîte le
gaming
j'ai été construit comme un personnes au
genre sans le titre toujours quoique
tout profond donner les mêmes permission
que j'avais au hockey l'argent
l'affectueuse avec là il fallait que la
faculté d'aménagement accepte que chacun
des préfets que ça a été quand même
support mais tout le monde la paperasse
fois ont affecté des examens qui ont
donné au niveau national marchi pis moi
je lui faisais deux jours avant je signe
de la voir comme des coûts et
déguisements comme l'argent mais moi je
vous pose la question comment la
question telle est la question qui tue
10 par mois a accepté ce pitt avait le
niveau pour faut vraiment fascinant avis
et mai
je pense que surtout que jamais la
dépendance aux jeux vidéo ça se paie ou
qu'elle à quel point les jeunes jouent à
ce saut tacot parce que le c6
d'anecdotes les métiers y ait quelqu'un
proche de moi que
son fils qui est comme j'ai la donne
si fait que mais qu'est ce tu es que
comme prenant soin dans le temps et il
ya des problèmes de sur poté y joue
jamais dehors au rieu de cbe y sa seule
valorisation dans la vie provient des
jeux vidéo qui s'y met ton il devient
pro gamers qui fait son envie gens c'est
vraiment cool sauf que si j'eusse comme
l'alignement la ligue en dessous qui
finalement ivre pas c'est bon pour faire
ce mais qui quand même qu'un toutes ces
eaux là dedans ça nuit à d'autres fois
de sa vie le statut
faut savoir que déjà le monde dépendent
d'elles faut faire attention parce que
je dirais la cyberdépendance est super
rare dépendance 6
dans je me lave plus
il veut plus sortir ils mangent presque
puis d'or pu et puis d'interactions
sociales et ça affecte toutes les
facettes de sa vie et ses supports et
pas pour des excès de jeux vidéo sur ces
paroles et mais c'est pas parce que tu
prennes exigence forme avait exemple
quand même énormément de gens qui jouent
pas le jeu vidéo mais qui vont regarder
notre flic c'est votre heure de temps
phénomène pourtant son plancher et on
voit en fac cécité on voit pas
nécessairement que des malades mais je
pense que plus largement les jeux vidéo
je pense que les écrans général se doit
de netflix ce soit ton téléphone
pour moi c'est un peu toute loi est la
même pour moi le problème c'est que
désormais le jeu vidéo c'est plus notre
consommation des technologies - tu auras
pas
d'autres affaires je fais souvent la
métaphore du brocoli si on mangeait que
du brocoli entrevoir un petit mariage
est exclusivement ce ton qui ne fait que
du jeu vidéo
ouais c'est hank est défectueux du jeu
vidéo
c'est pas parce qu'un jeu vidéo de
naissance et mal et un skate
vie baillet pas balancer dans sa vie key
vraiment voir ça comme un brocoli est
pas un parent qui va de la marche pas
trop mal oui c'est mal et qui peut pas
dire à ton gêne je pose jeu vidéo c'est
marrant parce qu'ils s'y est pas seul
problème le problème c'est son équilibre
de vie ça balance
si et
c'est des fois c'est d'autres problèmes
beaucoup plus profond que seul le fait
qu'ils se meurt dans le jeu vidéo est
justement terminé un point vraiment
important de dire c'est que ce n'est pas
sa seule valorisation des dons dans le
jeu - mais ce
c'est super important pour quelqu'un de
se sentir valorisé sur terre la
naissance ici c'est que dès que tu
fermes les craintes de rechute de
réalisation ou metz c'est en fait si
j'arrête de jouer au soccer puisse
pardon sa cure mais j'arrête mon jour de
sa vie je m'en veux et jouer un jeu ce
fonds diversifiés l'important c'est la
balance
bon ok qui le sait lequel les parents en
barque
parce que les parents et ont une super
et en influence énormément importante
sur comment leurs jeunes gèrent leur vie
si les parents les empêche de jouer ou
lors de ces mâles aussi totale
interaction que les jeunes passent aux
jeux vidéo et ses parents c'est que
c'est négatif
sacré que les jeunes se renferme encore
plus puis souvent un autre que moi
c'était comme cela c'est que sam
j'arrêtais pas de jouer ça changeait
rien dans ma vie mais et
je commence à me sentir comme la merde
intérieurement mais changez pas
nécessairement mon habitude s'est lancé
dans l'ain vers ce qu'il faut faire il
faut aller dans les autres les parents
se mettent à jouer s'intéresse au jeu
mais il faut que les jeunes par eux
mêmes veulent changer et comment par eux
mêmes tu veux changer c'est que si toi
tu embarques dans son délire pda qui ont
regardé de trois parties fenêtre la
pression on va les parts de marché que
les chiens aux rêveurs petit à son
écriture comprend non seulement les
parents comprend et verte net et c'est
commencer une partie connaître la
longueur et ça ça veut dire que
maintenant tu veux faire des super avec
la famille ça en jeu vidéo rien le sort
de ceux qui aiment faire deux parties
prenantes carrière de l'école dont une
heure d'étude de partenaires comme le
passe-partout ont su exact ne pense pas
qu'il était important qu'il faut c'est
d'avoir la base de ce qui est à faire
deux parties prenantes quant aux deux
parties prenantes
on mange de ça moi c'est cette société
le taf a inscrit maman a crié qu'il
reste 50 minutes peut-être partir de la
dernière game 2 cs et je disais ok je
parte mais malgré tout après marie dorin
game je découpais lagarde janvier marie
merle
je sais que mon équipe et moi même
aujourd'hui parlons pas j'avais une
heure et demi par an sans écran de
téléphone d'ensemble sans rien puis
cynique par étapes à franchir
ton corps d'un homme était le jeu vidéo
comme une autre activité quitté soit la
danse ou alors c'est vrai mais ça fait
partie des
ma routine des pommes c'est parce que je
l'avais intégré dans ma famille on peut
nous condamnons pas d'orgie mi-temps
pendant un cours de piano ou huit heures
par jour mais très pratique pour moi
mais c'est moins addictif que je pense
pas que si mais c'est quand même un
travail qui à faire avec la personne
parce que ce soit les jeux vidéo c'est
une personnalité type addictives
ouais je peux le faire avec n'importe
quoi comme je deale bobines jouets
jake's tu vas et tu vas peut-être joué à
ton téléphone
c'était une personnalité comme ça que
c'est sur les jeux vidéo ou autre il ya
des chances que tu tombes
je suis accro mais s'il faut faire
attention au moins cool mais comme
vraiment intensément dans l'excès là
dedans qui faut aussi faire attention
parce que le problème c'est que les
parents souvent ils savent pas faire la
france antilles par dépendance excès et
passion enthousiasme
puis je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de gens
qui sont dans la passion enthousiasme et
à cause que les paroles l'untec baudens
dans leur quotidien loos les jeunes
peuvent tomber dans l'excès parce que
c'est comme une espèce d'être souvent la
dre sens où si tu veux que le monde
n'est pas aussi l'ailé avec la basse et
la ligne mais pour savoir que et
comme tout dans la vie sink ascendance
puis comme tout dans la vie faut que les
parents entrent avec le jeune ben si
c'est que c'est tellement difficile à
gérer pour un parent cette situation là
parce que admettons que tu veux donc qui
comprend des cadets comprendre que ton
jeune il est enthousiaste et aime sauter
et là tu veux pas tu peux pas le
restreindre parce que je me dis je veux
c'est ce que je veux faire c'est ça que
j'aime france je veux te rassure quand
même temps
eux c'est
c'est dur d'essayer de le restreindre
pour essayer de lui montrer d'autres il
donne même des parents ça m'amène un
autre affaire qui te dit qu'il était
vraiment intéressante a dit si jamais il
réussit pour avoir perdu son temps à
fondamente s'il devient pas pro x les
moteurs étaient exactement mais il faut
savoir que en 2018 et procès
jobs au québec
pour l'heure c'est vraiment comme le
sport la musique l'art
s'ils t'ont jeune et très bien mais ça
lui développe tellement de belz habilité
pour le marché du travail
c'est incroyable que ce soit est pas
parce qu il devient pas un pro pour être
prêt pour être journaliste
il ya toutes les facettes des autres
communautés actives citons gen suwa qui
jouent au foot m comment tu peut
orienter sa passion comme attends tu
veux dire c'est petit à prendre le
chemin à faire des vidéos pour youtube
de ce qui est à présent faire ça serait
cool y apprend à faire du tout y apprend
à faire des vidéos et dating agents ou
tu dis est triple jeu ça me tenterait de
les rejeter inscrire dans un enfer pour
faire des petits jeux des crèmes jours
dit il pour faire des jeux vidéo l'acte
i je peux t'inscrire une semaine 15
jours trois peut-être apprendre ferrand
juste après ça m'intéresse
puis le labo il va parler de fortes avec
ses amis thibault tripes et il va
apprendre à programmer par bloc 1 jour
10 ans et moi je faisais des sites web à
10 ans j'appris l'acheter même tout seul
parce que mon père m'a steiner dit
notant qu' on n'avait même pas internet
que ce même site internet sa culture
j'ai apprécié parce que mes parents
m'ont laissé comme explorée par qui
aujourd'hui c'est payant parce que je
peux me débrouiller en ramassant figé
j'ai travaillé là dedans pour combien de
fois que c'est pas parce que ça passe on
est orienté jouer jouer je jouais qu'à
peut pousser s'épanouir dans quelque
chose qui va le toucher
même s'il n'est pas pro
peut-être que votre ip entre des tas de
questions un artiste peut-être qu'ils
étaient menés vers quoi je comprends qui
il ya quelques jours google goog de prix
video games
j'ai fait tous les jours pour monter
tant que justement pour m'inspirer
il y avait
je t'ai pas capable de rentrer dans une
semaine le nombre de trucs positifs qui
a appris que tu apprends quand tu joue à
des jeux vidéo son propre combat mais
tout google quand même why it's good
things loyer du bail ou de celle qui se
sont honnêtement il y en a pas autant
que ce taux s'est dit lassé par
dépendance c'est vraiment très rare
ça c'est ce que ça dit aussi qu'en titre
google et les deux choses qui osent
c'est la cyberintimidation la sphère
dépendance qui va mal et les deux gros
qui mange je vois jouer à plus lexique
et la super dépenses parce que comme je
dis c'est en fait je parle plus d'excès
qui et c'est pas irréversible qui si
souvent c'est vraiment un manque
d'encadrement et
mais peut-être pas pour la séparation
nation parce que c'est un problème de
société lexsi c'est vraiment et puis
j'ai peur qu'on est tous des mauvais
parole sinon parce que des fois c'est
vraiment des mais les parents savent
maintenant pendant que la prochaine
génération votre plus ajoutent-ils
mais oui puis non parce que moi je
change vite tout - pour moi c'est pour
moi tout ce que je vous disais il a
fallu que je fasse des recherches que
j'ai appris que je fais mes amis il est
donc une ici ont des enfants le ils vont
les élever un peu comme nos parents
comme ça pour ça que moi je pense que
c'est un phénomène de société qu'il faut
faire une différence d'un système
d'éducation faut outiller nos profs
parce que nos parents peuvent pas faire
tout seul et vice versa nos preuves
peuvent pas faire ça tout seul ça qu'il
faut les aider et puis ça s'est super
urgent pour moi mais on s'en fout et un
bateau qu'il meurt il va frapper le pire
c'est pas juste au québec le sait
pertinemment pour toi qui se met les
mains je suis coupé surtout que les
mobiles
mais natixis est de match tout seul
parce que cette personne que je connais
kannad bush alors j'ai la do bcc que
célibat savent savent plus quoi faire
pis ces nostalgiques d'une époque
poutine en france et peut-être pas le
sama mieux moi car chez georges et jouy
des amis ces pilules je sais pas ça sent
encore mais je n'ai pas sans peut-être
que ça c'est moins pire
c'est peut-être pas mieux ou moins bons
médecins les parents de ces petits
gravillons dit pourquoi justement tu
avais pas d amis à maison pourquoi que
vous avez pas jouer dehors
c'est mes amis sont tout sauf une sont
toutes en ligne c'est seulement est ce
que tes amis sur la cale du jeu de
succès que des québécois est bien écrite
et des dream city le y en a encore
d'abord pour les invités pour un loup ou
ce qu'ils jouent ou schizo gaming café à
montréal où août et où quelque chose que
c'est possible de québec lui il s'est
fait des amis sur internet
qu'est-ce que je peux faire pour en
apprendre sur ces ces personnes le puits
les regrouper des puits situés genre et
aux motifs mon kid à ramasser de
l'argent pour aller voir son ami ou
gérer utah d'en pêtre le jodo le texas
qui était son but dans la prochaine
année c'est qu'ils travaillent par fort
pour qui jouer avec son ami août et
xhosa fortnight genre waouh quel beau
but pour un petit jeune dix actes et le
san mamés
souvent ces seules et parra tente de
déconnecter le jeu avec la vie du kid au
lieu de l'intégrer avec et une belle
nuance par exemple communauté sait
vraiment comment tu peux prendre ce que
lui fait trip parce que lui le soir ce
programme s adresse pas avoir de
nouveaux amis il est à 7 ans je sais pas
si grave si une passion c'est déjà il ya
plein qui n'ont pas de passion que
certains coiffeurs qui est qu'ils
peuvent tomber dans d'autres sur la fin
bref lui très forte net comment qu'on
peut prendre ce ce côté faut reconnaître
l'appui le faire qui vont grandir leurs
débuts des personnes par rapport à ce
qui je pense que c'est là que les
parents sont souvent démunis parce que
d'autres connexes pour les jeux dans les
intéressent peau ils savent même pas
pour rien qu'il ya des amis d'un joueur
qui parle du manque d'enjeu
il ya tellement d'affaires qui peuvent
être tournée autour de cette idée qui
fait juste jouer à forte tête qui peut
être positif dessin tu peux faire que ça
le motive avoir de quoi d'autre lui si
tu seras sur les tumeurs sont
accessibles coupe deux fois par année
dans les conventions
c'est peut-être s'offrir des tramways
citadis aux alcools on va pour aller
rencontrer need you out jusqu'en mai
prochain alors que des motivations qui
qui fait que les parents comprennent les
pros mais par an soit 60 entre chaque
des tournois en france puis me paraît y
ont des équipes préférées au tact et ils
portent leur gilet de gaming que je leur
donne quand jared un tournoi sont
fiables ils sont à l'arrêt au parc du
mont par son audi dreamhack le pied
comme puis de pareilles on leur dit de
remarques ils sont comme on est là
tchèque en 2010 2 mars et c'est une
pareille en parc
est-ce qu'ils ont embarqué dès le début
non vraiment posée au début ça lisent ça
leur faisait pas j'allais faire des
landes trois jours de suite avec qui
m'ont fait pareil ne va pas lâcher
quelle magie fax et accepte que moi ça a
toujours été ça
jveux peu importe que tu ne dis pas
qu'ils sont tous l'acceptent qui ont
travaillé avec son ou des couches
pendant trois jours que tu sais pas ce
qu'il pense a comparé entre jouer le
joueur puis le mont palomar gens d'ici
mes parents m'ont parlé moment et on
dira qu'ils ont l'accès pour les braises
on veut en faire partie il est
impressionné par être à peu près à
chaque tournoi même si à montréal il
venait me visiter une journée on les
retrouve nasa soit regardé mes parties
puis encore aujourd'hui écoute il faut
écouter le podcast
il écoute tout tout tout ce que je fais
sont intéressés c'est une des raisons
pourquoi moi je pense que j'ai autant eu
du succès aussi parce que j'avais deux
personnes en arrière pour reporter au
lait beurre la difficulté financière
émotionnel tout ceux qui ont quitté leur
pépite mais c'est pas grave si jean ça
va bien aller
tu fais bien sûr c'est ta passion est ce
que c'était pas nue dans ce que tu dis
ok go on continue
soulève la question parce que je pense
aux notifications beaucoup de gens se
posent je pense que qui t'amène vraiment
belles nuances t'amène se tait ça
dédramatise vraiment beaucoup le
ce phénomène le fait que non c'est
vraiment cool pitre et dans le fond je
pense que le nom des messages aussi
s'éduquer
c'est l'équilibré dans le fait que ce
fait que que ce peut être un problème et
qui sera fait pas mal nexity fait autre
chose toute une vie saine équilibrée
dans le fond ce contentieux recul un
petit peu aussi le jaune si c'est un
conseil aux parents de jeu s'intéresser
à ce que son jeune mais je suis surtout
pas saisir mongel est ta maison ne fait
pas de mal avec moi j'aime et que sa
maison même si je pense qu'il fait de la
république soit maison que soudain rue 1
ça peut être vrai ok mais à long terme
ça va pas dire que tout ce qui fait
derrière l'écran c'est bien c'est
possible aux antilles fit ce que ça lui
va bien mais qu'il faut pas se dire
payet chez nous dans le sous-sol qu'il
fait pas mal à persuader tout va bien
mais parce que c'est pas vrai importe
2018 dans un cas où est ce que
maintenant la linotte à l'école
commencera en souffrir piloter vraiment
qu'ils auraient des problèmes plus
graves
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire et dessus
écoute je peux spécialisée dans le sas
et soeurs mais
sûrement derco oui ça c'est sa fiche en
est marre des paquets pour savoir que
les écoles comme tous les eyed peas
creps dans les écoles primaires et sans
mal ils font face à ce tous les jours
parce que ça ne nous dit pas isoler les
décos d'excédent d'anjou dans l'internet
où tu sais c'est quelque chose qui
arrive un peu son programme aussi pour
aider parce que leurs pages de notes
c'est ça c'est pas dans laissez pas
causer quelques excuses moi je les
maires exprimé c'est pas ça arrivait à
voir qu'il ya des gens sont un peu ça
aurait pu être la consommation de
n'importe quoi d'autre des intérêts et
accueillons des ressources qui
s'applique aux jeux aussi comment
redresser un jeune quand ça va pas bien
c'est moi j'ai eu des passages où je
tripe et puis école qui vous dépasse
tout ça allait super bien que l'école et
je veux seulement sortir le meti je me
souviens mon cégep une chose que le
cégep c'est facile mais j'ai une chose
que c'était facile parce que coline je
rêve aura coulé tous mes congés tête je
jouais tellement à compter sur tout et
pourtant j si j'ai un bac pitre
ça veut pas dire que tu es les remarques
des nantis baisse que tu es mon but est
de passer les quais ça peut pointer
réversible et on en a tellement
d'exemples dans la société de gens qui
ont eu des problèmes qui sont capables
de remonter factice ton génitrice jeu
vidéo g en bleu et la paire x 4 préface
d'un essai négativement puis de rentrer
dedans parce que c'est l'autre qui est
important pour lui que tes parents soit
le favori tout celui ci a des problèmes
à l'école puis tu réussi à redresser sa
avec lui de façon positive qui me semble
impacter sa vie aussi parce que 60 ans
que ses parents sont le ouais je sais
qu'ils se battent allemands qui ont la
chance d'avoir des parents comme ligne
et le jeu je suis choyé je pars dans le
peuple
beaucoup beaucoup d'histoires de
quelques fonds des storylines gamer pan
de l'histoire que ça revient à la même
histoire
mes parents ils voulaient pas vraiment
que je sois si chanceuse mais
ça prend plus vendue ici c'est important
de juste être
bon ça a tout changé 800 jeunes cool ça
l'est
telle est la question c'est ça tu peux
pas répondre demain sinon c'est quelque
chose qu'il montre questionne beaucoup
de formes souvent pour des questions
l'homme de points mais j'ai jamais le
temps de l'aborder autant profondément
que sur la beauté du podcast exact pis
c'est comme si ce jeu dommage dit star
j'ai fait un tête à queue mercredi pile
le sujet que j'ai pris c'est ce qu'est
ce que j'aurais pu dire elle tant que
service appelé my life de prog émue pour
adhérer ça m'a répliqué je veux comme je
veux être capable d'en parler je veux
faire une science je vais montrer
comment le jeu vidéo n'est pas le mal
mais ça pourrait être mon juste prix
c'est que ça reste dans les ja c'est bon
c'est bon mode merci beaucoup sur la
recherche
j'avoue que j'imagine que vous avez dû
faire de la recherche parce que vous
étiez quand même au courant de certains
trucs de ma vie puis ça change vraiment
les tractions que je peux avoir avec les
rats qui on ne te dirais pas que c'est
un sujet en tout cas pour moi qui étais
vraiment agréable à rechercher les mois
je connaissais ph connaît plus ce monde
que moi
bref à la fin c'est d'avoir ces
importants trop souvent m'arrive puis on
est justement catapulté dans une version
des slides mais c'est pas vraiment et
qui oui ça me surprend pas mais n'y a
pas le temps mais on était des entrevues
tarifs la personne ses facultés qui se
dresse face va en fait c'est pas mal et
là c'est juste que ce propos si loin ça
reste vraiment surface mais des faux
témoins c'est plate le faire 50 rentrée
j'imagine que c'est la même chose qu'à
quai et quand ils font la promotion d'un
film sur l' horrible
ben affleck parle de batman superman ou
est-ce que je me posais une question
plus la caméra zoome sur lui avec leurs
lots de nessma voyez comme ça ça donne
la paix mais ça va être quand même chez
nous parce que l'on fasse plus que ces
deux mots claquent à cette plainte mais
ça fait merci aux coups bas et tout le
monde merci beaucoup